>> Tucker: THE MIGRANT CARAVAN
FROM HONDURAS WAS HEADED FOR
THIS COUNTRY BUT STOPPED SHORT
IN MEXICO AND IS NOW OCCUPYING
THE BORDER CITY OF TIJUANA.
LOCAL RESIDENTS AND TIJUANA ARE
GETTING INCREASINGLY FED UP
ABOUT ITS PRESENCE.
HE RECENTLY SAID THE CARAVAN
LEADERS TRICK PEOPLE INTO
TRAVELING NORTH WITH FALSE
PROMISES.
HE ALSO SAYS A CARAVAN WOULD BE
BETTER OFF RETURNING TO THEIR
HOME COUNTRIES.
>> I'M LOOKING AT A PICTURE OF
YOU WITH SOME KIND OF ENCAMPMENT
BEHIND YOU.
CAN YOU TELL OUR VIEWERS WHAT
YOU ARE LOOKING AT?
>> WE ARE LOOKING AT A FACILITY
THAT IS LIKE AN EMERGENCY
CHAPTER FOR THEM.
THEY ARE GOING TO TRY TO CROSS
THROUGH THE BEACH, OR JUMP THE
FENCE.
YOU HAVE TO BRING THEM OVER HER
HERE, AND THEY WERE GETTING MAD
AND THEY EVEN STARTED THROWING
STONES AT EACH OTHER.
THEY KEPT GROWING AND GROWING.
BUT WHEN WE WERE CARRYING THE
FINANCIAL LOAD OF KEEPING THESE
PEOPLE WITH MEDICINE AND FOOD
AND SHELTER, AND ITS -- >> I'M
SORRY TO INTERRUPT BUT BEHIND
YOU IT SEEMS THAT SOMEONE IS
CLEANING UP GARBAGE.
IS THERE LOTS OF TRASH THERE?
>> THERE IS A LOT OF TRASH
BECAUSE WHAT I TRY TO TELL YOU,
THE 360 GREW TO 6300.
SO WE HAD ANOTHER, IT'S A BIG
CONCERT HALL WHERE YOU CAN HAVE
LIKE 10,000 PEOPLE.
WE SENT THEM OVER HERE BUT IT
HAS TO BE VOLUNTARY BECAUSE THE
PEOPLE FROM HUMAN RIGHTS, THEY
HAVE THEIR DELEGATES HERE, TOO.
AND THEY WANT TO -- THEY WANTED
TO TREAT THEM TOO KINDLY.
SO THERE ARE LIKE 1500 PEOPLE
HERE, 2200 PEOPLE THERE AND
THERE ARE LIKE 2,000 PEOPLE THAT
AREN'T ACCOUNTED FOR.
>> Tucker: UNACCOUNTED FOR.
SO BASICALLY YOU HAVE ILLEGAL
ALIENS FROM HONDURAS IN TIJUANA.
HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT THAT?
>> WHILE I HAVE HEARD THAT LIKE
THE BORDER PATROL HAS BEEN GOING
UP IN DETENTIONS.
LIKE 150 MORE THAN THEY ARE USED
TO.
THERE WERE          THERE WAS AN
THERE WERE          THERE WAS AA
THERE WERE          THERE WAS AC
THERE WERE          THERE WAS AD
THERE WERE          THERE WAS AN
THERE WERE          THERE WAS AT
THERE WERE          THERE WAS AW
THERE WERE          THERE WAS AH
THERE WERE          THERE WAS AE
THERE WERE          THERE WAS AG
THERE WERE          THERE WAS AT
PEOPLE DEAD IN A PICKUP TRUCK.
SOME OF THE PEOPLE ARE STAYING
HERE.
THE ONES THAT ARE OUTSIDE HERE
IN THE STREETS, THEY SAID IT
BECAUSE THEY ALREADY STARTED
THEIR PAPERWORK FOR GETTING WORK
PERMITS HERE IN MEXICO, THEY
WANT TO STAY IN MEXICO.
THEY KNOW SOMEONE POPPED THE
BUBBLE OF THEIR AMERICAN DREAM.
200 HAVE BEEN REPATRIATED HOME
VOLUNTARILY AND WE HAVE DEPORTED
MORE THAN 200.
THERE HAVE BEEN LIKE 236
DETAINED BY POLICE AND WE SEND
THEM THROUGH THE IMMIGRATION
SYSTEM.
>> Tucker: IT SO YOU ARE
DEALING WITH SEVERAL THOUSAND
UNWANTED IMMIGRANTS IN TIJUANA.
THE UNITED STATES RIGHT NOW HAS
ABOUT 22 MILLION ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS            ALIENS
LIVING WITHIN OUR BORDERS.
CAN YOU UNDERSTAND IT, NOW THAT
YOU ARE SEEING THIS FIRST HAND,
THE FRUSTRATION OF SOME
AMERICANS ABOUT THAT?
>> THE PEOPLE FROM TIJUANA ARE
FRUSTRATED.
THESE PEOPLE CAME HERE LEGALLY,
THEY WENT TO OUR BORDER AND THEY
STARTED WITH A WORK VISA, A
STUDENT VISA TOURIST VISA.
A LOT OF THEM DO THAT, THEY TRY
TO DO THEIR PAPERWORK ALSO TO GO
LEGALLY INTO THE UNITED STATES.
MANY OF THEM HAVE FAMILIES
THERE, A LOT OF THEM HAVE
FAMILIES IN CANADA.
I TALKED WITH PEOPLE FROM THE
CANADIAN EMBASSY AND THEY HAVE A
PROGRAM THAT UNITES FAMILY,
MEXICANS OR HONDURANS WHO ARE
WORKING THERE AND THEY HAVE
VISAS FOR THAT.
BUT THESE GUYS DIDN'T CROSS
LEGALLY INTO MEXICO.
THEY TORE DOWN OUR BORDER AND
JUMPED.
THAT -- THAT SYMPATHETIC.
>> SO FINALLY HOW ARE YOU GOING
TO RESPOND WHEN THIS HAPPENS
AGAIN BECAUSE THIS WILL NOT
LIKELY BE THE LAST CARAVAN THAT
COMES THROUGH TIJUANA?
>> THIS PRESIDENT HAS A VERY
DIFFERENT MIND-SET FROM THE LAST
PERSON.
THIS PRESIDENT SAYS WELCOME, WE
ARE GIVING YOU A JOB AND WILL
CREATE OPPORTUNITIES FOR YOU.
AND IN TIJUANA WE ARE WORRIED
AND WE ARE WAITING FOR THAT TO
HAPPEN IN THE NEXT DAY.
THE OTHER SHELTER THAT WAS IN